Hey Youtubers it's Charlie and JJ Abrams is
reacting to all the Episode 7 leaks in a really
funny way. It kind of makes me think that
the leaks are orchestrated, but whatever the
case is I'll do a breakdown of what's happening
on the set. They also just announced Josh
Trank who did Chronicle is directing one of
the spinoffs and there's a special event happening
on Thursday that I'll explain.
If you're finding me for the first time I
do bonus Star Wars videos every week, be sure
to subscribe to get everything and please
leave suggestions for bonus topics. Originally
this video was going to be my top 10 characters
I wanted to see come back. So that will probably
just happen next week.
Lots of Star Wars happenings to talk about
so let's start with JJ Abrams and the leaked
pictures. A bunch of pictures from the Tatooine
Set leaked as well as pictures of big Millenium
Falcon and X-Wing props under construction.
Regardless of whether or not the leaks were
intentional, JJ Abrams posted this picture
to twitter as a clever way to say he's pissed
about the leak, but yes. The Millenium Falcon
is in the movie.
That's the chess board from inside the Falcon
underneath his letter. Just out of respect
I'm not going to use the leaked photos in
my video here.
As big a deal as this was, Yahoo Movies reported
the Falcon was going to be in the movie a
long time ago. So it's not really new news.
But there is a certain spectacle to seeing
it in real life.
As for production status, the movie just got
done filming all it's Tatooine scenes in Abu
Dhabi, they're shooting in London now. It's
the same soundstage they shot the original
trilogy on. And the same studio where they
shot Avengers 2.
They just added two more big actors to the
cast too, Gwendoline Christie who plays Brienne
on Game of Thrones and Lupita Nyong'O. We
don't know who they're playing, but the best
theory I've seen is that Lupita is playing
a sith warrior like Asajj Ventress. I really
hope Brienne gets to be a Jedi Knight. On
game of thrones that's all her character wants
to be, but she's not. So it would be sweet
justice to let her be a knight in star wars.
This thursday there's a special Star Wars
event happening. I'll be doing a video for
it so no worries. But it's Dave Filoni from
the Rebels Cartoon. It's called Star Wars,
Past, Present and Future. It's mostly going
to be a talk about the evolution of storytelling
at Lucasfilm as it applies to all the new
Star Wars stuff happening.
That video will probably post Thursday afternoon.
So if you're already subscribed just follow
me on social for updates. I might live tweet
it. Links for twitter and facebook down at
the bottom of the description.
On to New Spinoff Happenings, don't be surprised
if every time they announce something for
Episode 7, they also announce something for
the spinoffs. But they just hired Josh Trank
to do another one of the spinoffs. So right
now they have Gareth Edwards doing one and
Josh Trank doing another. Leaving one more
director. Originally Lawrence Kasdan and Simon
Kinberg were each going to do one, but one
of them might have to drop out because of
scheduling conflicts.
Either way, there hasn't been any official
word on who's doing which movie or which one
is coming first. But my earlier theory was
that Garreth Edwards was doing the Red 5 movie
first, so I'll guess that Josh Trank is doing
Boba Fett or Han Solo.
In case I didn't mention it earlier, we also
don't know if those spinoff movies will be
origin stories or if they'll fit sequentially
in the new timeline. Like the first spinoff
picking up directly after Episode 7.
The really cool thing about this Josh Trank
news is that he did a short Star Wars fan
film in 2007 called Stabbing At Leia that
helped him get his first big job directing
Chronicle for FOX. The film looks a lot like
what Chronicle ended up being with the shaky
cam in real life look. It also just happens
to have some Lightsabers. I think of it as
like a dude bro fight with lightsabers.
Trank is also directing the Fantastic Four
reboot, which is scheduled for June 2015.
Because that movie is so soon, either they'll
reschedule it or he just won't start working
on Star Wars full time until next year when
post production is finishing up. That movie
is FOX, so you can see how studios like to
stick with directors they've already worked
with. Star Wars is Disney, so if everything
goes well with his spinoff, don't be surprised
if you see Trank do more Disney films.
And if you're a big fan of the expanded universe
novels. Disney relaunched what they're calling
their adult fiction line of books with 3 new
ones that will all be part of the new movie
canon.
The first one is Tarkin, obviously about Grand
Moff Tarkin that's coming later this year
and then next year there will be two books.
Heir to the Jedi and Lords of the Sith. That
first one is out in January and the Sith book
is out in March. So presumably they'll deal
with the events leading up to Episode 7.
The Rebels cartoon is also canon, but that
takes place a couple years after Return of
The Jedi and the new films pick up about 30
years after that just to give you an idea
for the timeline.
I know I haven't really done book reviews
on my channel yet but there are a lot of books
coming in the next year that I'm really excited
about. Not least of which is Winds of Winter.
So if there are any Star Wars Expanded Universe
books or stories you want me to do bonus videos
for just let me know in the comments.
Based on them shoving the Expanded Universe
canon off to the side I think it's safe to
say that the backstory for the Jedi the Sith
and Grand Moff Tarkin will be pretty different
from what they did with those characters in
the Dark Horse comics and the Del Rey novels.
I think most of what I learned about Tarkin's
backstory was through Admiral Daala. I think
the last time she appeared was in the Fate
of The Jedi series. That was meant to be a
big transition from a lot of classic characters
to the newer ones like the Solo Children and
Ben Skywalker.
That's all before Disney bought Star Wars,
now they're starting fresh again.
The only other rumor I want to include here
is actually for Indiana Jones. Disney is making
plans for a new Franchise and Robert Pattinson
is the current favorite to take over the role.
I'm sure that will inspire a lot of love or
hate depending on where you fall.
So, like I said, special Star Wars event this
Thursday I'll be doing a video for. Prepare
thyself. I'm also doing Fault In Our Stars
and Edge of Tomorrow videos. So lots of fun
stuff coming.
Right now click here to learn more about the
Boba Fett spinoff movie and click here to
learn about my picks for the new Doctor Strange
movie
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!